so now it's time to actually implement
the changes we talked about in the last
video to start with I'm going to open
the create screen in an image editing
software i'm going to use paintbrush a
free image editing software for macs but
feel free to use whatever software you
like so for me i'll go up here go to
open and browse my way to the correct
screen so now that i'm here what we're
seeing is that we have this event
language here and if we're else in the
class we use this language of task so
the first task for us will be to change
this event word to task now it's fairly
easy to do that in program like this I'm
actually just going to like copy this
command C command V and cover that up
it's not the cleanest but it works and
with as with all prototyping what works
is what you should be doing so let's
remove this event word from the screen
now we need to add the task word to the
screen so this won't be ideal but it
will actually convey the information
we're trying to convey so now that I've
done that I can save and then I can
close out if we wanted to upload this
that in my prototype was now using it we
would press this plus button see how it
says drag and drop we can simply go up
to create drag that and drop that and
because it has the same name we now have
task over here anytime you're uploading
a screen to your envision prototype
which has the exact same name as a
previous screen it will override that
screen so now when I go into this screen
that we've just created and I go to the
build mode you'll see that it already
has these hot spots and so it already
knows that it's supposed to link back /
clothes when I press the create button
now let's think another thing if we want
to have these checkboxes show up
somewhere and they need to be good well
the first place we encounter checkboxes
was the
calendar day so let's open up this
calendar day in our image editing
software so as we can see it currently
has these check boxes which are these
gray circles and then they turn into
blue circles with checks in them that
was confusing some of our users so again
we're going to just cover this up no
need to be fancy with it and then we'll
replace that so I like paint brush
because it comes with this nice tool for
just putting out rounded boxes so I can
just make this square check box I'm
holding the shift key down to make sure
that it's actually square and then I can
switch over to this copying tool again
grab that and copy it on down I'm going
to try and line these up but they won't
be perfect and that's all right again
you want the least time spent on your
prototype as possible so again we've
cleaned this up it's much better we have
these checkboxes let's save and upload
that screen so again so again click this
plus button and move the calendar day on
over so by doing that we've now gotten
these check boxes here and we've now got
all of the hot spots already there so we
can click on this and go to the week or
the month create an event go back to
this drawer the final thing we wanted to
do is make sure the home screen had
these checkboxes and we can do that in
one of two ways either we can take our
current home screen and add the check
boxes or we can take a look at this
calendar day see that it has all the
same information as our current home
screen but also has checkboxes and say
well maybe we don't need actually this
home screen anymore so instead I'm going
to go through the hot spots that we
already have and change them so that
rather than pointing at home they
pointed calendar day to do that I'm
first going to go into this
view part then I'm going to click on
build mode and that'll bring up all the
hot spots so the way I've done this home
is the one that currently points at the
home screen we want home to point at
calendar day so we just change that
click Save and now if we go back to our
preview mode click on home it will bring
us to calendar day there are a few other
places will need to do this change so
let's move on through the first place is
in your sign up screen usually when you
click this create for create an account
it will link you to home or to your walk
through you can change that to calendar
day if you like if you have it pointing
at the walkthrough then you have to
change this to point a calendar day and
again every time it's very simple click
on this click on the drop-down go to the
right screen and then click Save so
here's our home we don't actually have
to change anything from this home to
remove it from the prototype all we need
to do is change the things that would
otherwise point to this home screen so
going through this it looks like there
aren't any other places where we know we
need to change the hotspot there are
places where we might have to change the
hotspot depending on how you implemented
this new screen this create might go to
link back close or it might currently be
pointing at the home screen similarly
for this back button up here check those
before you move on the last one is this
sign in very often this we pointing
towards home and you'll want this to be
pointing towards calendar day with all
of that done we can go to our preview
mode and click around to be sure that
we've done this right so let's try
signing in and wonderful now we're on
this screen with the checkboxes that's
what we wanted if we take a look at
creating a task we now see that it does
say in fact task it's a little bit
spaced weird but it took us five minutes
to do wonderful now your test project
should have reacted to all of the
feedback we got in our first round of
user testing which means of course that
it's time for more user testing